dans ce bureau de vote de sainte-marie
au milieu des urnes isoloirs et autres
bulletins de vote
des objets moins habituels comme ces
lingettes désinfectantes et cela
commence dès l'entrée avec ce point deux
équipes et de savon quant à
l'opportunité d'un vote dans le contexte
actuel du coronavirus elle est
diversement appréciée selon les
électeurs c'est un peu compliqué puisque
sa fille et moi je me pose est atteint
votre site très important je poste
aujourd'hui à maman nous a pas beaucoup
de monde aujourd'hui au fait que les
gens refusent de se dépasser
ça passe sur tous les personnages chers
et plus jg il est remporté les élections
encore l'expression populaire soit
rester de façon plus nette
ici la municipalité a pris d'autres
dispositions et suivi les
recommandations nationales comme ces
isoloirs tourner vers les murs pour
garantir la confidentialité tout en
évitant la manipulation des rideaux aux
heures de rush l'accès à la salle est
limité les membres du bureau ont eux
aussi font preuve de prudence
je prends pas la tête je regarde le nom
le prénom son enveloppe gel douche là en
2014 le taux de participation était de
60%
l'on saura ce soir si le risque
épidémique aura finalement découragé les
électeurs